so now let's talk about shepard smith on
fox news because we act that what's
going on with trump and ukraine is so
crazy it's so out there in terms of the
the seriousness and the brazen nature of
it that not one but multiple Fox News
hosts have been trying to insert some
dose of reality into coverage of the
story so we already talked about Fox
host John Roberts confronting Rudy
Giuliani on the Fox Sunday program that
was great to some degree that it
potentially pierced the echo chamber of
some of the Fox News audience this was
not the only time that the Trump Ukraine
story was called out Shepard Smith tried
merely telling the truth pointing out
that the issue here is not Biden its
Trump's phone call which we now know was
preceded by a few days with Trump's
order that hundreds of millions of
dollars in military aid to Ukraine be
withheld and Shepard Smith tells it like
it is there's no evidence that the
allegations against Joe Biden have
anything to them no facts support the
allegation that Biden did anything wrong
here really piercing the narrative of
the average Fox News viewer take a look
they failed with Russia they failed with
recession they failed with everything
and now they're bringing this up the one
who's got the problem is Biden as you
look at what Biden did Biden did what
they would like to have me do except
their one problem I didn't do it there
is no known evidence that Biden did
anything wrong the whole thing involved
corruption in Ukraine a corrupt
prosecutor who much of the world was
pressuring Ukraine to remove earlier
this year over Ukrainian officials said
there was no evidence of any wrongdoing
by Joe Biden or his son hunter the real
issue here is the phone call the claim
that the president pressured a foreign
leader to investigate a political rival
and the failure to pass the whistle
whistle blower complaint to Congress now
among Democrats pressure to impeach this
president is building Shep speaking
clearly accurately and truthfully this
is not a pat on the back to ship this is
what every news reporter should be doing
this is what we would expect
on every Network simply saying here is
what we know happened here's what Trump
is alleging and there is no evidence for
what Donald Trump is alleging here now
fascinatingly Shep Smith is not on Fox
News at 3:00 a.m. he has like a normal
daytime newscast now that being said the
middle of the afternoon Eastern Time is
not exactly the hot time to be doing
news but Shep is telling it like it is
at least on some issues and every time
that this happens I get emails from
people in my audience saying David Shep
has no place at Fox he should really be
elsewhere and again I've said before
Shep is not going to take down the
broader narrative of Fox News as a tool
of the Republican Party but simply being
there and getting to tell the truth
every once in a while Shep is invading
the otherwise unfettered trumpian
narrative that the Fox News audience is
generally speaking used to and that's a
good thing and I was looking at some of
the comments online from the Fox News
audience about this segment and you see
the normal stuff about no one cares what
you think mrs. Smith I saw referring to
Shep Smith or no one likes this
effeminate outburst
stuff like that homophobic stuff about
Shep Smith everything that you would
expect I still think that there is some
good done by chef Smith's presence on
Fox News even though it also potentially
as I've said before does provide some
cover to Fox to say we've got some
conservative editorial stuff going on
but our news is right down the middle
and pointing to Shep Smith which is of
course a total distortion of the overall
balance of what we're getting on Fox
News let me know what you think let me
know what you think about Shep's
presence on the channel